y
[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo en
france 24 gracias por estar con nosotros
mi nombre es juan pupiales y basa en
cabo la retirada de las tropas
internacionales y la evacuación de miles
de afganos después del mortífero
atentado del jueves según la agencia
reuters la cifra de fallecidos sería de
al menos 92 incluyendo 13 militares
estadounidenses de las fuentes afganas
hablan de hasta 169 decesos de pentágono
confirmó este viernes que fue un solo
suicida el que perpetró ese ataque y
advierte que sigue habiendo amenazas
para la seguridad a cuatro días de la
fecha límite fijada por washington y el
grupo talibán para abandonar el
territorio
isaac en explosión no creemos que una
segunda explosión en o cerca del hotel
barón fue solo un ataque suicida no
estamos seguros como ese reporte fue
hecho de forma incorrecta pero lo que
sabemos es que no es de extrañar que en
medio de la construcción en eventos tan
cambiantes como este la información a
veces se brinde erróneamente o sea
distorsiones que encajase information
sometimes mientras tanto la organización
mundial de la salud advierte que es
cuestión de días para qué caben las
reservas de material médico en
afganistán
la oms plantea habilitar el aeropuerto
de mashad isaf al norte para permitir la
llegada de ayuda por su parte la agencia
de refugiados de la onu acnur alerta que
la actual crisis podría desembocar en la
salida de 500.000 refugiados para fin de
año these are there merchants son
tiempos dramáticos y acnur la agencia de
la onu para los refugiados ha trabajado
con el pueblo de afganistán durante más
de 40 años y nos mantendremos a su lado
haremos lo que podamos para apoyarlos en
cuanto a números nos estamos preparando
para unos 500.000 nuevos refugiados en
la región
eso en el peor de los casos wo whistle
aunque aún no hemos visto grandes flujos
de afganos hacia el exterior la
situación dentro de afganistán ha
evolucionado más rápidamente de lo que
se esperaba
pasamos a hablar de temas de la pandemia
porque la unión europea habría acordado
restablecer las restricciones de viaje
debido al 19 como cuarentenas y pruebas
para ciudadanos no vacunados procedentes
de estados unidos y otros cinco países
según fuentes de la agencia la decisión
sobre estas nuevas limitaciones de viaje
del bloque para los extranjeros serían
aprobadas el lunes en caso de que ningún
país del organismo comunitario se
opusiera la lista se compone en base a
la situación de cobo y 19 en cada estado
así como a la reciprocidad
en nicaragua la justicia continúa con
medidas que están afectando el futuro
político de los detractores del
presidente daniel ortega
el jueves la fiscalidad acusó a ocho
opositores con cargos de conspiración
tres de ellos serán posibles aspirantes
a la presidencia en las elecciones de
noviembre en total en los últimos tres
meses 35 opositores han sido detenidos
en el país centroamericano
terminamos con noticias deportivas
porque el portugués cristiano ronaldo
regresa al manchester united y el club
en el que se hizo grande en europa la
noticia sorprende porque gran parte de
la prensa europea especulaba con un
traspaso del delantero luso al match del
city de pep guardiola
finalmente ronaldo pasará de la juventus
de italia al united por un contrato de
dos años y en un fichaje estimado en
unos 25 millones de euros
y este viernes france24 y todo el grupo
fans me diamond dedica gran parte de su
programación a la situación de las
mujeres en afganistán sus conquistas
durante las dos últimas décadas y los
derechos que podrían perder ahora que el
grupo de talibán retomó las riendas del
país por eso despedimos este avance
informativo con estas imágenes
y
[Música]